hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my arrow episode 3 video a lot of
team arrow og team arrow stuff happening
so let's get into it careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen the episode
yet in Brooklyn run or two there's a new
round of the reverse flash ring giveaway
this week all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
this video so let's get going starting
with top 5 WTF Diggle vs. Oliver so they
they finally lay this beast to rest
nothing is more unpleasant than watching
your main characters fight it out like
you want them to be a team you want them
to have fun and beat the crap out of
villains so they finally make nice
Diggle comes clean about hive 2 been 2
years we have more in common than you
think Diggle if it wasn't clear a lot of
the reasons that Diggle has been acting
this way is because it's eating him up
inside that he has been unable to make
any headway in solving his brother's
murder he feels like he's been
completely failing this so that just
that gets lumped in with all the stuff
that happened to Lyla last year so the
reason he's been so pissed off at Oliver
is mostly because he's pissed off at
himself
that's all good now let's all have a
drink oh gee team arrow Felicity was on
point this week especially with the og
team arrow stuff I mean I mean she was
great in all her scenes but I just I
loved the way they opened the episode
original gangsta what a coincidence that
she ended up using a submachine gun
later in the episode on the number 4 OG
felicity is final boss form felicity
best recognize there's a lot of reasons
why the Felicity character is so much
more fun the season you know just the
way the writing heard the kind of arcs
that are giving her like boss mode
Felicity much more fun than assistant
Felicity she does get kind of bossy
pants in the episode but that's only to
slap Diggle and Oliver to their senses
like she just like get a hold of
yourselves figure this [ __ ] out
you're messing everything up they kind
of need that like Oliver can be really
stepping on his own and Diggle is being
really really stubborn who else noticed
like all the little things that Felicity
said that she thought that she might be
doing at some point in her life but
she's like at one point I thought mine
might be a dental hygienist or a
molecular biologist she's just like an
expert at almost everything mr. terrific
is probably an expert at all the things
that she's not an expert at you have to
remember that even though they've
changed mr. terrific a little bit from
the comics just the way the characters
portrayed a lot of the creative energy
is still there he's still one of the
smartest people on the planet but for
the most part his role in Team arrow
will be as an inventor
like coming up with new technology the
way Cisco does Cisco's more of an
engineer though he's better at building
stuffs what I'm really hoping to see is
cisco help mr. terrific build his tee
spheres better like mr. terrific
develops the technology Cisco's the
character you would go to to actually
put it together and make it work right
on the number three though mr. terrific
knows Felicity's secret now but not
Oliver's what Felicity meant by that is
that mr. terrific knows that Felicity
works with the arrow but he doesn't know
that Oliver is the green arrow although
you know I mean he'll probably find out
at some point this season it wouldn't be
a new season of the show if people
didn't learn Oliver is identity the same
things gonna happen with Barry and patty
spivot on the flash pretty soon - first
things first though they have to save
the company pretty clearly these t
spheres are gonna have something to do
with that
now the t spheres in the comics can do
all kinds of stuff all they're doing
right now though is blowing up they're
just spontaneously exploding so they
just this is the show's way of telling
you that the t spheres won't be a thing
for a couple more episodes if there's
anything that I don't think that they'll
let them do on the TV show just out of
practicalities sake it would be using
the T spheres to fly like mr. terrific
can actually stand on them and he uses
them to fly around I'm not expecting the
show to do that in in terms of costumes
like mr. terrific ticking on his comic
book persona
I think he'll look mostly like this for
the rest of the season maybe in a future
season if he's still on in season five
or six then he'll get some sort of
costume to think about how long it took
Diggle to get that suit I would put T
sphere completion somewhere around
wherever this project Genesis stuff is
going on with damian darhk-- they
name-dropped phase three now obviously
we have no idea what that means we have
no idea what their timeline is but I
would venture to guess it has something
to do with the mid-season finale like
it's all culminating towards some big
point when the rest of hive rolls into
town and she gets real speed which on
our number two damien darhk's grand plan
so he demonstrates his abilities again
and it looks like a form of tactic
Kinesis but he calls that a parlor trick
and in that conversation they also call
out to project Genesis so because he's
heavily involved in mysticism I'm
wondering if what he's doing has
something to do with raising demons or
you know something with the spiritual
plane Constantine is coming on in
Episode five
now he's mostly gonna be involved with
Sarah's storyline fixing her so I don't
know how
involved he's going to get with the
damien darhk's storyline but they can do
one of those things where he continues
to help them from off-camera so when we
do get to that Constantine episode in a
couple weeks just listen for any
references to what might be going on
with damian darhk-- and finally on to my
number one WTF moment they resurrect
Sarah in the Lazarus Pit Nyssa tanks it
and Thea and consequently Sarah are both
going to have to kill people to quiet
the souls inside of them so first things
first they brought Sarah back this is a
really big deal I actually wasn't
expecting to have this scene till the
constatine episode but the way this
played out I think I think kind of
explains things so Sarah is just gonna
go crazy
until Constantine helps quiet the souls
inside of her or maybe the explanation
is is that she doesn't even have a soul
right now and Constantine has to find it
either way Sarah is completely crazy
pants she is like what Thea will turn
into eventually I think that's the idea
like deal will eventually devolve into
what Sarah's like right here so
Constantine will come help fix Sarah I
think Thea's solution will take a little
bit longer I think that'll be more of an
internal battle that she'll have to deal
with some of you did ask me though about
Rachel goal like the ratio goal that
Oliver killed last year still being
alive because Merlyn says that Thea
needs to kill the person who wronged her
and since she thinks he's already dead
Merlin's like well you'll just have to
keep killing people that's that's the
only way to keep from going completely
crazy but here's the big question if you
have to kill the person who wronged you
does that mean that Sarah is going to
have to kill Thea obviously I don't
think that Thea's gonna die there it's
gonna be a shitstorm between the three
of them between Merlyn Sarah and Thea
until Constantine arrives then you have
to think about what's going on with
Nyssa she wants to get rid of Malcolm
Merlyn she completely hates him
especially since he aided in bringing
back Sarah
so she tanks the Lazarus Pit I mean
obviously there's more Lazarus pits
around the world that we haven't seen
yet this isn't the only Lazarus Pit but
she just took away Merlin's
ace-in-the-hole so like he has no more
cards to play if he dies he ends up
staying dead but the other thing I
thought was really interesting too is
that when he's talking to Thea he says
there's nothing I wouldn't do for my
daughter and II you know you like he
threw those league members under the bus
under the Thea bus what if Nyssa uses
that let that type of like crazy energy
to try and lead a coup against Merlyn
it's just because the episode was titled
restoration so I also think she's try
to restore her birthright let me know in
the comments though what did you guys
think about the resurrection scene with
Sarah lanced
I mean did did you like that or do you
feel like you were expecting something
even bigger I feel like they're trying
to get this out of the way now so they
can actually have some fun with caity
lotz on screen you can have Black Canary
squared kicking butt like they have a
birds of prey episode that's coming up
with both Canaries in it and Thea so if
you feel like they did it too soon it's
just because they want to get to the
good stuff even faster but speaking of
good stuff don't forget that all of her
teas that he has a new arrow lair in the
works I mean I still call it the arrow
cave even though they call it the lair
you can call it whatever you want but I
felt like even when Felicity was like
you know machine-gunning the crap out of
DoubleDown that was kind of the impetus
that like okay well we're gonna destroy
this arrow cave so we're gonna have to
build a new one that was gonna be the
catalyst for making the new lair but it
turns out that Oliver had one playing
the whole time
Felicity is just gonna be the one to
bankroll it and yes this is totally Ray
Palmer that's messaging Felicity or
trying to message her that that's what
all this weird text is about it's just
that when you're really small like that
Felicity wouldn't be able to hear him
just the sent sound waves don't work
that way
when you're really really tiny so using
the computers is the only way that he'll
be able to talk to Felicity so they'll
just they'll develop that plotline as we
go along I think the strongest actors
this week we're probably felicity like
she had some of the best scenes in Thea
when she was going really really crazy
like when she slowly killed that one
League member like she just drew the
blade across his neck so vicious Thea is
having more fun this season than almost
any of the other actors on the show but
what's gonna happen in tomorrow is I'm
gonna catch up with my Gotham video I
still need to post a Gotham video for
this week and then I'll try and get q
and A's out for Game of Thrones and
arrow and the flash there was so much
Star Wars stuff at the beginning of this
week that I had to rearrange a bunch of
stuff so get hype Constantine is coming
soon it is gonna be awesome just in case
you guys haven't seen it you can click
here for last night's episode of the
flash and you can click here for the
Star Wars Episode 7 trailer thank you so
much watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight